journ abam his home in
gaz to is he says the shooting as they
left was continuous even though they had
white flags he also said the israel army
was using a drone to force people to
die andle this is a the journey that he
made
with old come on  But you
walk, come on, be afraid with one hand. Come on,
Dido, Papa Mam, come on, don't be afraid, Mamou, what's wrong
with you, Abu
Ahmed? I swear to God, you brought me the house, come on, bring me, come on, come on. I
said to God, stay at home, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Abu, come on.
I can't carry it because I have a child, come on, carry it, carry it, carry it,
say, oh Lord,
say, oh Lord, yes, yes, hey, I'm still alive, I'm still alive, I still have a
father, come on, bring me the bag, the bag,
without a bag, without anyone else. I'll go,
but daddy, daddy,
daddy, what's up, what's up, what's up?  Is there anyone who can imagine, oh, there are
three things, okay, ha, answer the lip, answer the
lip,
answer the lip, answer, come on, God willing, from [
music]
God [music] ba [music]
[music]
ba
g